VINOD RAMACHANDRAN:
Hi, welcome to session,
serverless functions--
FaaS-- that are secure,
scalable, resilient anywhere.
My name is Vinod, and I'm a
product manager at Google.
And I am presenting with
my colleague Dustin Ingram,
and Matthew Lawson from IKEA.
So let's get started.
So here's today's agenda.
First, we'll give you an
overview of the product, Cloud
Functions.
Then we'll walk you
through key function
as a service use cases.
Then we'll follow up
with an interesting case
study from IKEA and their
digital transformation
with serverless.
After that, we'll walk
you through a key security
capabilities and diagnosability
and availability capabilities
in serverless at
Google Cloud, and then
walk you through our
functions everywhere vision.
So let's get started.
Cloud Functions--
Cloud Functions
as Google's
event-driven serverless
compute platform
where users can write
small snippets of
code that react
to events as well as HTTP.
You can write up these
functions very easily
and get started to process
small snippets of code,
say, for example, uploading a
file to Google Cloud Storage
and do some processing, also
wrap up with some ML APIs,
do some ML processing
on the file,
and then store the
results back in the cloud.
Cloud Functions is
truly serverless,
where you pay only
for what you use.
It scales seamlessly with zero
infrastructure management.
It also has a streamlined
development model
where you can wrap up and
write a function very quickly.
In addition, it's
integrated with key events
all across GCP to build up
complicated applications
and services.
When we talk to
users, users really
like to use Cloud Functions
for its simplicity,
scalability, the
fact that you don't
have to manage servers, the
pay for use model, and the fact
that it's connected to a
broad range of cloud services.
Key functions as a
service use cases
that our customers use
Cloud Functions are things
like servers web hooks, where
users can write up functions
with GitHub notifications that
are processed and then served
in Slack; further,
real-time data processing,
wherein users can upload data
to the cloud, to Cloud Storage,
triggered a function to do some
processing, call an ML API,
and then store the results
in the cloud again;
serverless IoT backends,
where users have
IoT systems all
across the world,
sending things like sensor
and temperature data.
And then that's
processed through Pub/Sub
messaging systems that
trigger Cloud Functions.
And then you do
some IoT analytics,
and then store the
results in the cloud.
And then our intelligent
applications, using
AI in BigQuery, for example,
chat boards using Twilio,
where functions are
wired up to invoke
an ML AP or a natural language
processing API, as well
as doing sentiment analysis
with that and trend analysis
with BigQuery.
Along with these
key FaaS use cases,
when we talk to customers,
they have several key FaaS user
needs that come up.
And these needs are things
like developer productivity,
building complex enterprise
workflows with serverless
and functions, building
applications that are secure,
and then having the ability
to build applications
with multiple languages,
with diagnosability,
debugging capabilities,
telemetry,
and local development.
Further, users will care
about global availability
and scalability to ensure the
application and function scale
for their application traffic.
In addition, users really
care about portability
and can we reduce vendor lock-in
when we build our serverless
applications?
And to meet these user
needs, Cloud Functions
offers the following
key differentiators.
First is ease of use.
Cloud Functions is a
very easy-to-use product,
where users can write up
a function very quickly
from the UI, from the CLI,
from their favorite IDE,
and from an API.
For example, here's a
simple function in Node.js
where a user's just written
"Hello, Cloud Next!"
The user quickly writes it up
and deploys it using the CLI.
And then it's ready,
serving traffic.
All in a single command, the
user is writing their code.
It's getting built in the cloud.
It's getting deployed in the
cloud with health checks.
And then it's, within
minutes, running
and ready to serve traffic.
This is really powerful, that
all in a single command, a user
can get this and
achieve so much.
Along with the ease of
use, Cloud Functions
offers the ability to build
complex end-to-end solutions.
These end-to-end
solutions can be
built using key powerful
building blocks, which
are event-based, for
things like data processing
with ML APIs, and BigQuery, and
so on, and then for automation
workloads, with things such as
Cloud Scheduler, Cloud Tasks,
and so on and so forth.
And to walk you through this
application journey of bidding
end-to-end applications,
I would like
to now invite Matthew
Lawson from IKEA to walk you
through IKEA's
digital transformation
with serverless and
Cloud Functions.
MATTHEW LAWSON: Hello, and
good morning, good afternoon,
or good evening,
depending on what time
it is wherever
you're watching this.
I'm very happy to do this
presentation for you today.
But of course, I
would have loved
to have done this in person.
But because of the
current global situation,
I get to do this from my
home office here in Sweden.
So in this talk, I'm going
to explain to you how
IKEA is using Google Cloud
Functions and other serverless
technologies in our
engineering efforts
as we go through a
digital transformation.
So my name is Matthew Lawson.
And I work at IKEA as
an engineering manager
here in southern Sweden.
I usually don't start
my presentations off
with who IKEA is, but I do have
a couple of company slides--
two of them, to be exact.
So first, maybe I
can share something
that you might not know about
IKEA, and that is our vision.
It has very little
to do with furniture.
Actually, it has nothing
And that is to create
a better everyday life
for the many people.
So whether it's becoming
one of the world's leaders
in sustainability, starting
to sell solar panels,
working with
international charities,
or creating that great furniture
for the home, all of this
to help the many people
to create that better
everyday life.
But the two words out of that
vision that mean the most to me
are "many people."
And to let you know what I mean,
let me give you some numbers
here.
So IKEA is over 76 years
old, and is made up
of many companies,
organizations,
and hundreds of thousands of
co-workers across the globe.
So here are some highlights
from our previous fiscal year
as of September 1, 2019.
So IKEA had 433 stores
open, with 12 of them
opening that fiscal year.
And actually, within the last
few months of this recording,
we have over 450 now.
We have 211,000 co-workers
working for us globally.
And this is growing, especially
in our digital organizations
across the globe.
And we're now opening small
stores in city centers.
As an example of this,
within the first four months
of opening, we had
a million visitors
to our IKEA La Madeleine
store in downtown Paris.
We have billions of visitors
to our website each year.
And we have over 100 million
IKEA family, or our loyalty
program, across
the globe as well.
So this means that when we
create a new physical product
or a new digital product, like
a mobile web, web application,
or an API, we need
to make sure we
cater to those many people,
the millions of people.
So IKEA, as in many
different companies,
are going through a
digital transformation.
IKEA has been around since 1958.
And to be completely
transparent,
we have quite a bit of technical
debt across the organization,
or what we like to call
it is our spaghetti
in the data center.
Our digital transformation
was not simply
a matter of migrating
to the cloud.
One decision we
made early on was
how this was going to happen.
We did not want to
do a complete lift
and shift to a cloud partner.
But instead, we
decided to re-engineer
the organization and digital
products at the same time.
Our chief operations
manager stated
once, "We are flying
a plane and changing
the engine at the same time."
Personally, to me, this
is quite hard to do.
But as an engineer, it
has been a ton of fun.
So our new solutions
and projects
are striving to be
completely cloud-native.
And this is quite
hard to do when
the brain of your
application, the data,
is still sitting on premise.
And we're doing a lot of
work in that area internally
as well, creating new data
pipelines to cater both
to the old and the new.
So one of the use cases that
we started re-engineering
that is heavily
using Google Cloud
Functions and many other
serverless technologies
is our almost live feed
of our inventory system
that we have at each IKEA
location across the globe.
So this enables us to
show a live feed of what
is selling, allowing us to
export that data to BigQuery
for further analysis, and also
to create dashboards to give
the store insights on
what is happening instead
of that daily or weekly report.
And I'm sure there is
much more use cases
that we haven't even
thought up of yet here.
So let's take a look at
a architecture of one
of the use cases that my fellow
co-worker Michael created.
First, we have our
inventory server,
which sits on premise
at each IKEA location
and talks to the Google Cloud
through a Compute Engine
from the shared VPC on a VPN.
And this sends many
different messages as XML.
The XML is then compared to
Google Cloud Storage, looking
for new or changed rows.
And the ones that are changed
are sent, as JSON object,
to a Pub/Sub topic.
We then have a
batch receiving side
of this, which uses Google Cloud
Functions and actually powers
this entire architecture.
This pulls in
messages from Pub/Sub
and puts the raw data into
many different BigQuery data
sets depending on
the message type.
And we can also
move that message
on for further processing
using other Pub/Sub topics.
Finally, we're pulling
in the messages
from the capturing Google
Cloud function using a schedule
system as well, that
was built. And this
is using Cloud Scheduler,
another Google Cloud function,
Cloud Tasks, and
this configuration
data stored in Firestore.
So this tells the Google Cloud
function, the capturing one,
how often to execute
depending on some criteria
like the amount of messages
in the queue, time,
and also optimizes everything
from a cost perspective
as well.
We then can create
custom dashboards
using the BigQuery data sets.
And we can also
process it further on,
like I said, with
Pub/Sub topics.
One aspect of this architecture
that we're currently working on
is the ingestion of data
from the on-premise server
to the cloud.
We're looking at how we
can do this without using
a VPN tunnel or a shared VPC.
So some people
have asked me, why
are we using Google
Cloud Functions here
and not something like Dataflow.
Well, one thing we like
to say here at IKEA
is we do not respect a solution
until we know what it costs.
And if the solution was to be
turned into mission-critical,
then we could change
the architecture
to better support message
ordering, duplication,
and other aspects.
This solution currently
handles between 60 and--
40,000 to 60,000 messages
per minute and can
certainly scale
higher, as we've seen.
And it actually costs
around $30 US per month
to operate to get the data
from on premise to Google Cloud
Functions.
And so this really showcases
the power of serverless
without needing to
spend a ton of money.
So let's take a
quick look at a demo
that my colleagues Axel
and Joel created to show
what you can do with this data.
So here is a map of North
America with our stores.
And for fun, we're just
showing our inventory changes
from our iconic product
the FRAKTA blue bag.
So as you can see here,
we're getting some messages
popping in from sales that
are happening in those stores.
And this really
showcases how you
can use serverless
technology to bridge
between what you're doing
on premise to new cloud
technologies.
So with that, if you have
any other further questions,
you can please feel
free to contact me.
My email address is here.
And also, as I mentioned,
we're also hiring.
So please visit join.ingka.com
for more information
around that.
And with that, I thank
you for listening.
And please stay safe out there.
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN:
Thank you, Matthew,
for that amazing presentation
on IKEA's digital transformation
with serverless and
Cloud Functions.
Now moving on, one of
the key user needs,
as well as security--
Cloud Functions offers key
security differentiators
for users in serverless.
One of the key features we offer
is per-function identities,
where we provide fine-grained
control on which users
are privileged to
invoke a function.
And we take it a step
further and also provide
around which specific resources
a function has access to.
For example, here's a user
who's trying to invoke a Cloud
Function using Cloud Scheduler.
And you know that
user is authorized.
And the user can
invoke the function.
And then there's
a malicious user
who is trying to invoke
the same function
and is prevented to do so.
Likewise, here is
a Cloud Function
that has permissions
to access BigQuery,
but it does not have permissions
to access Cloud Storage.
By providing these fine-grained
controls on security,
we really help users control
who can access the function
and which resources a
function can access, and then
take the security
level a step further.
Along with that, users
really care about VPC.
They have systems across the
cloud as well as on prem,
in VPC networks.
And our Cloud Functions
play really nice
with these VPC networks.
Functions can connect
with VPC networks.
And we take it a step
further by providing
what is called VPC SC,
or a security perimeter,
to prevent things like
data exfiltration.
Along with fine-grained
access and VPC,
users are really
concerned about the denial
of wallet attack in serverless.
For instance, if a
user service gets
a lot of requests
from a malicious user,
they could, at the
end of the month,
get a shocking bill if
their scaling is not capped.
To prevent this, we
offer a service called
max instances that let users
cap their serverless services,
thereby preventing the
denial of wallet attack,
and also letting their
serverless services scale
to the extent as needed and
within their monthly budgets.
Along with scalability
and security,
users really care about multiple
languages, diagnosability,
and local development.
Cloud Functions, today, is
available in key languages
such as Python, Node, and Go.
Further, we're super
excited to announce Java 11,
which is generally available,
as well as .NET and Ruby and we
have more runtimes
coming soon as well.
And to talk to you more about
diagnosability and fault
tolerance, I would like to
know invite Dustin on stage
to give you a demo
in this space.
DUSTIN INGRAM: Hi I'm Dustin
Ingram, developer advocate
for Google Cloud.
Let's take a look at how we can
build a reliable, resilient,
self-healing system using Cloud
Functions and Cloud Pub/Sub.
Let's say we've got a fleet
of deployed IoT sensors
that are sending temperature
data in degrees Fahrenheit,
along with a sensor ID and
JSON payload, via an HTTP post,
to a Cloud Function.
Now say we want to take
that temperature data
and write it to Firestore, which
is our operational database,
and also write it to BigQuery,
which is our data analytics
warehouse.
Traditionally, we
would probably do
this in the same application,
or in the same function.
But this has a couple drawbacks.
So if, for example, the
code that writes to BigQuery
is not available,
or has a bug in it--
or maybe there's a
networking glitch,
and it can't talk
to the service.
Now the function errors out.
And you're left
in a weird state.
Should I rerun the function?
But then, what if Firestore
write did succeed,
and now I've written
to Firestore twice?
What is the overall
state of my application?
So we want to decouple these.
Now one way we could
do this is to put it
into two Cloud Functions,
one that writes to Firestore
and one that writes to BigQuery.
And this is a step in
the right direction.
But that postTemperature()
function is still responsible
for running, and retrying, and
understanding if those other
functions succeeded or failed.
So we want to decouple
these completely.
And to do that, we'll
use Cloud Pub/Sub, which
is a high-scale messaging
bus on Google Cloud.
Now all postTemperature()
has to do is write a message
to the Pub/Sub bus,
and then it's done.
The writeBigQuery() and
writeFirestore() functions are
listening for messages coming in
on that topic in Cloud Pub/Sub.
When they get those messages,
they'll do their functionality.
And they'll fail and
retry independently
from each other asynchronously.
Let's take a look
at this in action.
Here are the three Cloud
functions that we talked about,
postTemperature(),
writeBigQuery(),
and writeFirestore().
I've written a shell script to
simulate the IoT sensor posting
their data via an HTTP post.
So they're going to post it
to this sensors collection
in Firestore.
And you can see these
values coming in.
But we've also got
a tracking sheet
that we wrote that this actually
looks at the timestamps coming
in and puts in a message
when it's about to try
writing to BigQuery--
I'm about to try
writing to Firestore--
and then whether it
succeeded or failed.
And you can see these
update in real time.
Everything is good, so
it's all successful.
But I want to simulate an
error in the, let's say,
writeBigQuery() function.
So I'm going to open up the
editor here in Cloud Functions.
There's a built-in
editor, but you can also
use your normal IDE,
your normal editor,
to deploy from your
workstation and so on.
But this is handy for
doing quick edits.
So I'm going to go here, and
I'm going to intentionally break
this function I'm going to
change the name of the table
from readings to, let's just
say, readings with a few S's.
So maybe one of our Python
developers made a typo
and put the wrong
name of the table.
So let's deploy this.
So I'm deploying a broken
version of the writeBigQuery()
function.
And while that's
deploying, you can
look at some of the other
attributes of our Cloud
function.
You can set identity so
your function can maybe
only access certain resources.
Or you can set
environment variables--
for example, the sheet ID
that we're doing updating in
All right, so now that
our function is deployed,
I'm going to rerun that shell
script that simulates 10
IoT sensor readings coming in.
And let's go look at
it in Google Sheets.
So you can see it's
succeeding and trying.
And you can see it's
happening asynchronously.
Those functions are running
and failing independently.
We've set Cloud
Functions to retry,
which means that if
it gets an error,
it will retry immediately.
If it gets another
error again, it'll
wait a bit longer, and
so on and so forth,
as an exponential back-off.
All right, so those
are all failed.
So we want to figure
out, OK, what went wrong?
Now I know what went
wrong, because I
put that typo in there.
But let's pretend that we
didn't, and we actually
need to debug this.
Cloud Logging
automatically picks up all
the logging messages from Cloud
Functions, but also Cloud Run,
App Engine, Kubernetes,
and a bunch of others.
And you can see, we can
identify our error here.
The table "cloud funcs
readingsssss" is not available.
So Cloud Logging is great.
You can do monitoring
and alerting.
You can have it
automatically aggregate error
reports using error reporting.
And it's a really
handy and useful tool
for debugging your serverless
code on Google Cloud.
So let's fix our
BigQuery function
I'm going to load
the editor back up
and fix it so that instead of
"readingsssss" with many S's,
it's just "readings" with one S.
And then we will redeploy this.
Now let's check
our tracking sheet,
where you can see it's actually
been retrying this whole time.
As it retries again with the
new version of writeBigQuery()
it'll start to succeed
now instead of failing.
And again, all we did was
redeploy the function.
We had to set Cloud
Functions to retry
so the data wouldn't be lost.
Because the system is
keeping track of it
internally as it retries
the function with the same
payload again and again
until it succeeds.
And that'll happen
for up to seven days,
retrying your Cloud
function so you don't have
to worry about losing data.
And that is how you can
build a reliable, resilient,
self-healing system
with Cloud Functions.
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN:
Thank you, Dustin,
for that amazing demo on
diagnosability and fault
tolerance.
Now moving on, when users are
using serverless and Cloud
Functions, they really care
about local development
and disconnected development.
Imagine that you're
working a team,
and you have take a flight,
a seven-hour flight,
and you want to continue
developing your application
that you're working
with on your team.
You can now do that
with Cloud Functions
as well as on your plane.
And then when you land, you
can connect with your team
and share your work as well.
To do this, let's unpack
what's really in your function.
A function is running
an operating system
for a particular
runtime such as Node.js
with a web framework for
that particular runtime,
such as Express, with
the Functions Framework,
and then with the user's
code and dependencies.
Everything in green below
is managed by Google.
And only the users code is
what is provided by the user.
And what we have
done at Google is
we have taken the
second green box, which
is the function's framework
for each language and runtime,
and open-sourced it.
We call this the
Functions Framework.
For example, here is
the Functions Framework
for Node.js on Cloud Functions.
Now with this
Functions Framework,
a user can run a
function locally
with their favorite IDE.
And here's an example
of the Node.js Functions
Framework, along with a Node
function, in your favorite IDE.
And then a user can
basically step through code,
write code when
they're on a plane,
and debug and test it, and
then [INAUDIBLE] with that team
when they land down.
Along with
diagnosability, language,
and local development,
users really
care about availability
and scalability
for their serverless services.
Cloud Functions is available
in a broad range of regions.
And today, we are super
excited to announce
that we have added 30 new
regions over the past year
for Cloud Functions, making
the total number of regions 19
where the product is offered.
With this global
availability of the service,
with super excited to
provide it to our users
in the broad range of
markets in the world.
Along with availability,
users really
care about scalability for
their serverless services
and functions.
Cloud Functions is backed
by Google's infrastructure,
which runs with [INAUDIBLE].
And it uses a technology
called gVisor,
which really helps it scale.
And here's an example
of a load test
where a serverless service
for Cloud Functions
is sent several
thousands of requests.
And we see that all of
the requests are served.
And none of them are dropped.
And the Cloud functions scaled
seamlessly in this test.
Along with availability
and scalability,
users really care about
openness and persuasiveness
of their application
and serverless service.
And here's a key differentiator
for Cloud Functions
in this space where
Cloud Functions,
with the underlying
Functions framework that
runs it and the build
mechanism to build it,
have all been open-sourced.
As a result, a user
can take their function
and deploy it to
Cloud Functions, which
is a fully managed product.
They can run it locally
in their favorite IDE
while they're on a plane.
They can also take that function
and run it in any environment
where you can run a container.
This could be Cloud Run, which
is our serverless containers
product, or any other
container environment
in other clouds as well.
This is a really key
differentiator for the product.
And now I'd like to
invite Dustin on stage
to provide you a
demo on functions
everywhere to walk you
through this vision.
DUSTIN INGRAM: If
we're a developer who's
not used to working
with containers,
let's see how we
can use buildpacks
to take our existing
Cloud Function,
with its simple
developer experience,
and have it automatically
turn into a container
that we can run anywhere,
including the powerful Cloud
Run, all without having
to understand Dockerfiles
or how to create a container.
You can use buildpacks
to turn your source code
into a containerized
application, either locally,
using the pack command, or
in Google Cloud Build, which
has support in alpha.
Buildpacks will look at the
source code of your application
and figure out what is the
language, what is the runtime,
and what will it take
to turn your application
into a container?
So in this case,
I'm going to use
the local pack build command.
And we'll give it a
destination where we
want to publish the container.
We'll also let it know that
it's a Google Cloud function.
This is the name of the
function within our file
that we want to run.
So if we go to my
container registry
and refresh, you can see, here
is the container that we just
built, see, just now.
And again, containers
are portable.
So I can deploy to Kubernetes
Engine or virtual machines
on Compute Engine.
But let's deploy
it on Cloud Run,
because it's fully managed,
just like Cloud Functions.
Once you're using
Cloud Run, you have
some advanced
configuration settings.
So you can customize
how much memory it has.
You can give it two CPUs.
And you have a longer
time-out in Cloud Run.
You can also do concurrency.
So one running instance
of your application
could handle multiple
requests, which
might lead to fewer cold starts
and more efficient usage.
And potentially, you can set
the minimum and maximum number
of instances.
Now that it's
deployed, you can see
that Cloud Run gives us a URL,
just like Cloud Functions.
But you can also specify
your own domain name.
Let's post some more
temperature readings
to that app that is
running on Cloud Run.
And if I pop over
here to Firestore,
you can see the data coming in.
Click here, and we
can prove that it
is, in fact, going into
the Cloud function that
is running on Cloud Run.
So we were able to take our
existing Cloud function,
with just source code,
and, using buildpacks,
turn it into a
containerized application
that can be run anywhere,
even the powerful Cloud Run.
VINOD RAMACHANDRAN:
Thank you, Dustin,
for that amazing demo
on functions everywhere.
Please check out Cloud Functions
at cloud.google.com/functions.
Please also check
out our Functions
Framework and buildpacks,
which are open-sourced.
The GitHub links
are provided here.
In addition, if you
have any questions,
please feel free to reach
out to Dustin or myself.
That's a wrap of our session.
Thank you, Dustin and Matthew,
for joining me in this session.
And I wish our viewers
a great confidence.